of course with less memory you're going
to run out of memory more frequently and
you'll have to make sure that your code
is bulletproof
in low memory conditions but this also
means that the garbage collector is
going to run more frequently and running
the garbage collector will actually
often also cause a spike in battery
usage so all of these are true however
the battery drain caused by the garbage
collector is less of a concern than
stuttering and other rendering problems
that the garbage collector can cause
when the garbage collector needs to
clean up it pauses all JavaScript
execution and rendering on your thread